pablo rodriguez bonjour bonjour avec
nous travaux parlementaires commencent
demain aux priorités prêter
libre-échange priorité absolue ça c'est
le numéro un à sa cdu mais roy j'ai un
deux trois c'est important pour
l'économie du québec c'est important
pour l'économie canadienne
on l'a négocié pendant un bon bout de
temps ce fait un an qu'on arrive à
négocier cette dernière mouture là on
s'est entendu là-dessus le mexique la
ratifient les états unis l'ont ratifié
santo ça passe au dessus bah j'espère je
l'espère pour pour les travail en avait
parlé avec des menaces mondiales tout le
monde la pire est quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse au sort des travailleurs de
nos entreprises voudraient pas
économique va l'appuyer mois dans un
monde idéal je m'attends skate monde là
puis on verra par la suite ils prendront
leurs décisions
mais ce traité là et les défauts d'un
mental pour l'économie du québec et et
l'ensemble du canada
comment se déroulent les discussions
avec avec les homologues des autres
partis là-dessus sur les ondes au dessus
aussi ben y'a rien qui nous faut
remettre leader du gouvernement
là j'ai pris mon téléphone puis je les
appelais chacun des trois et je leur ai
tout de suite laissé mon numéro de
téléphone portable je leur ai dit vous
m'appelez quand vous voulez 24 heures 7
jours semaine
et on ne parle vraiment sur une base
régulière c'est la seule façon de nous
entretenir une bonne relation
il ya plusieurs commentateurs
observateurs qui ont dit le gouvernement
de monsieur trudeau peut danser avec à
peu près chacun des partis si sur
différents dossiers on a l'impression
on a eu l'impression d'en passer
d'autres gouvernements minoritaires
gérait avec une relation avec un parti
si vous avez une communion d'esprit avec
plusieurs parties sur plusieurs dossiers
c'est plus facile le plus difficile de
la prochaine étape est de faire ton
approche et de ne prendre personne pour
acquis en terme d'appui puis je présume
pas que quiconque voter quand j'appelle
tout le monde et puis là je regarde avec
chacun d'entre eux c'est sûr que des
alliances naturelles
il est très possible on verra que les
conservateurs et puis le traité de libre
échange parce qu'ils comprennent
l'importance mais il est possible que
d'autres parts il appuie également sur
la question de l'environnement peut-être
que jon peddie le bloc vont nous appuyer
mais moi mon travail s'étend de la mer
d'oman
monsieur blanchet du bloc québécois
cette semaine a été assez ferme en
disant nous compte tenu de ce qui est
arrivé dans ce secteur de l'aluminium on
peut pas approuver sa vous avez eu
l'occasion de jaser avec son collègue de
libération comment vous envisager les
choses avec lui mais honnêtement je ne
comprends pas la position du bloc
québécois dans le secteur de l'aluminium
higuain il ya un minimum de 70 % de
contenu d'aluminium d'art américain dans
la production de véhicules dans
américain j'étais récemment avec
l'industrie de l'aluminium du québec qui
demande la ratification de l'entente
le premier ministre françois legault
l'ancien monsieur legault aussi l'île de
maui et la façon très ferme aussi les
chambres de commerce les prémices des
autres provinces ou six alors on verra
je comprends pas la position du bloc on
verra cette semaine mais il y aura
encore le temps de changer d'idée
d'après-vous l'un sa passe est quelle
vitesse c'est un baume incapable oui on
a fait c'est un les mêmes du parle non
pas dans les mains du même nom mais
c'est corrigé
on gère on tape on peut parler
minoritaire ce qui est important pour
nous c'est qu'ils aient acquis
suffisamment de jours de débat c'est que
les partis d'opposition se sente
confortable qu'ils auraient acceptant de
débattre et en chambre et un comité mais
qu'à un moment donné on puisse avoir
c'est ce que j'espère c'est qu'ils poids
deux mesures dilatoires pour essayer de
bloquer ou de retarder ça parce que là
c'est l'ensemble de l'économie
québécoise et canadienne qui appellent
au bon les autres dossiers prioritaires
qui ont été évoqués par monsieur trudeau
cette semaine à winnipeg
l'aide médicale à mourir le contrôle des
armes à feu commençons par l'aide
médicale à mourir
croyez vous être en mesure d'aller
chercher et consensus et d'adopter sans
rapidement comme monsieur la médecine
voudrait le faire
je l'écouté je l'espère une bonne dose
de consultations qui se passe
actuellement c'est normal dire quelque
chose tellement personnel de tellement
humain à l'intérieur de tout ça c'est
qu'on veut prendre le train de parler de
consulter des gens qui ont vécu que
vivent ces drames là en même temps on
est conscient qu'il ya aussi des charges
fixé par la cour alors laissé de
manoeuvrer à l'intérieur de tout cela en
tenant compte vraiment la dimension
humaine leurs priorités évoquées par un
monsieur trudeau veut bien
allez aussi contrôle des armes à feu ça
c'est moins 5 et déjà monsieur scheer
vendredi matin disait on n'aime pas ce
qui est on n'aime pas ce qu'on attend du
côté libéral à quel point ce que vous
pensez pouvoir faire avancer samedi mais
c'est sur un dossier prioritaire et on
l'entendre des maires des grandes villes
on entend des chefs de police on parle
pas ici d'un fusil de chasse le chasseur
le responsable utilisent pour les
défunts de chasse c'est pas ça du tout
lors on parle ici de d'armes d'assaut
qui ont été passés dessinée conçue
produits pour tuer le plus grand nombre
de personnes possible le plus rapidement
possible
ces gens ces anglais n'ont rien à faire
dans nos rues vous étiez en début de
notre vie vous n'êtes pas un gars de
procédure
et pourtant j'étais candidat c'est noël
les ménades jeunes que vous avez c'est
jaguar la cdu pourquoi pourquoi monsieur
trudeau a dit c'est vous qui allez face
ben je vous dirais que c'est à la fois
de genre de procédures peuvent à la fois
une job de relations humaines monde a
forcé les relations humaines c'est les
relations avec les collègues mais aussi
avec les autres partis la capacité
tendent la main par les dialogues et
s'entendre les procédures j'ai un paquet
de génie des gens bien plus intelligente
mans dans le bureau ici qui me conseille
et qui met déjà pas d'ailleurs à tous
les jours il ya bien des gens qui
regardent 5 et 10 et un rôle crucial
est ce que ça ne rentrera jamais dans un
parlement minoritaire fondamentale
absolument pourquoi cesser le délit de
détournement qui arrive ou non à établir
des accords avec les autres partis et à
bien des égards c'est selon son travail
un gouvernement pour pouvoir tenir un
bambou ou non votre plus gros défi
qualité dans ce boulot ben c'est de se
maintenir ce type de relation la même
l'amplifient la mairie avec les autres
partis être capable d'arriver une
relation on se fait confiance sachant
très bien qu'on ait des adversaires
politiques qui on le sait sont mais la
profondeur cette relation la maintenir à
plus long terme c'est un défi à quel
point c'est facile à faire parce que y
c'est réparé c'est très partisan un
parlement surtout minoritaires et même
dans de bonnes circonstances vos
prédécesseurs avaient de la difficulté à
certains moments
gérer les tensions avec leurs homologues
des autres partis à quel point est-ce
que c'est facile ou faisable
d'entretenir de bonnes relations avec
les gens qui font le même boulot vous
pour les autres il ya des choses qui
doivent changer et je pense que
l'élection tels que véhicule nous amène
cette possibilité c'est une élection qui
était très négatif traduit moi je n'ai
pas aimé du tout je connais pas un
canadien qui l'aimé cette élection là et
où là mais de ça je pense que chacun
d'entre nous tire la leçon de à l'effet
qu'on a changé qu'on doit être capable
de dialoguer de bacilles tôt un peu de
laisser faire un peu les insultes des
attaques personnelles parce qu'un
bowling n'y a personne qui gagne et je
pense que si on tire des leçons de cette
élection là on peut aborder les choses
différemment
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que la
responsabilité de rendre les débats -
partisans repose davantage sur vos
épaules sur ce qui s'est partagé sur
tous
est ce qu'ils ne comprennent pas ce que
je pense que oui les canadiens à
confolens les élections ne nous ont dit
on vous regarde
mais quand le vous étes trés accusés ils
nous regardent nous le gouvernement il
regarde l'ensemble des parlementaires à
nous tous une responsabilité c'est une
responsabilité collective nous pour
proposer des mesures législatives et les
défendre mais l'opposition aussi pour
débattre avec nous et faire en sorte que
les choses fonctionnent quand même quand
vous leur parlez à vos homologues quand
vous les a soignés autour de la table ce
qui est ce qu ils le sentent le poids du
pôle
pour le moment je le mentionne je pense
que tout le monde est d'accord sur le
fait qu' un parlement surtout un
parlement minoritaire et d'une certaine
façon son observation de la part des
canadiens de toutes les provinces
parlez moi de votre autre boulot qui est
lui attendu remake est pas rien quand
même ce non négligeable on a dit
plusieurs analystes ont dit c'est
important se lier la ce a sourcillé un
peu à québec quand on vous a nommé parce
qu'il ya des gens qui disaient pas bien
naturel un peu sur rodriguez le
gouvernement legault si on a des liens
varié où il ya bouille sur garde il ya
beaucoup de gens que je connais et des
ministres que je connais sur une base
personnelle parce qu'on a travaillé sur
des trucs ou dans le passé je suis allé
faire ma première visite lorsque
j'arrive au québec je rentrais à
l'assemblée au sénat je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait un paquet de gens
que je connaissais ici et là dans les
différents cabinets et est à moi et à
mon équipe d'approfondir scellier
apprendre à se connaître apprendre à
travailler ensemble parce qu'on sort
tous gagnants de cette collaboration a
encore monsieur legault dit moi mon
interlocuteur une ministre à quel point
ce bébé je lis il faut que ça continue
comme ça c'est extrêmement sain que les
prémices se parlent directement ses
écailles arrête de parler qu'il ya
problème à ma job ce n'est pas de
remplacer qui compte ni même un ministre
c'est faire en sorte de s'ajouter à ceux
d'être complémentaire de s'assurer
qu'ils aient pas de dossier qui tombent
entre les craques ce faire entendre la
voix du québec à ottawa notre
spécificité le fait qu'on est une nation
une société distincte
tous ces éléments là doivent être
entendus et compris hathaway s'est fait
partie nature et dans le contexte où le
travail de leader du gouvernement en
chambre vous gardant tahoua beaucoup
quel point est-ce que c'est facile de
2,2 de jouer les deux rôles de francs
mais moi je dirais que c'est très
complémentaire parce que de façon
générale les ministres vont rester
beaucoup plus ottawa qu'avant beaucoup
plus est lorsque la chambre siège japon
où suis-je au québec ça pour cent du
temps québec je ne penserai pas une
journée à caen le britannique ou en
ontario je passais mes journées en
abitibi ah bon ça québec au lac saint
jean pour être en contact justement soit
québec avec les membres du gouvernement
avec les verts des différentes régions
les chambres de commerce ainsi de suite
donc tout mon temps votre dévoué au
québec pablo rodriguez merci beaucoup
bon début de session
c'est moi qui vous remercie